Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two.
David, P..
Here's a viewer's opinion about whether it's
time for progressives to just kill the bill
because it's had so much gutted.
This is the spending and infrastructure bills
that Bernie Sanders discussed earlier in today's
program.
Speaker 7: Hey, David.
I just finished listening to your segment
about the now gutted infrastructure bill and
how more and more is getting pulled out to
appease Joe Manchin and and others.
I'm with you.
I'm at the point where I think that progressives
just need to say, No, there's nothing in here
for us.
We don't want it better than that, though.
I think what should be done if possible?
I don't know if it is, but bring it to a vote,
bring it to the floor and force Manchin and
for cinema to vote no on it.
And then that way, there's no denying where
they are, where anyone else is on their position
regarding this bill and regarding help for
the American people who pay their salaries.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I'm not against eventually
just get a vote.
And if they really aren't going to go anywhere,
get them on record voting against it, I'm
fine with that.
As I said, I was fine with it during the entire
force.
The vote on Medicare Thing, that Medicare
for all, that AOC, you know, I'm not against
getting people on record.
I'm more about trying to actually achieve
something.
So I don't need to immediately force a vote
right now.
If there's a chance that like, for example,
as Bernie Sanders said, and we played the
clip earlier.
If he is still working on getting prescription
drug cost controls in the bill, I'd rather
wait a little longer and actually get that
in the bill and pass it because that's better
for more people.
Ultimately, though, I do think that there
has to be some kind of limit.
And if we get to that limit and progressives
are better served by just killing the bill
at a certain point, you got to just vote and
get Joe Manchin to vote no and get Chris Kirsten
sentiment to vote no again.
Get them on record.
I'm not against that.
When the time comes, it actually does seem
that at least Bernie Sanders believes some
substantive progress could be made and some
major things could be put in the bill.
We have a great bone to show for you today.
We're going to talk about this just completely
botched revelation or announcement from Facebook
that they are changing its company name to
Metta.
A lot of people misunderstanding thinking
Facebook is now Facebook.
The app is now called Metta.
No, this is a corporate change.
Google is now Alphabet and it's still google.com.
Everything's still called Google.
Google Nest, Google Home, etc.
We will talk about a strawberry pop tart case
that is one of 400 lawsuits that a lawyer
has filed.
And when we talk about frivolous, we've got
to talk about this, and I think it'll be an
interesting discussion.
And then also outrage over a Southwest Airlines
pilot saying, Let's go Brandon, which is the
new it's.
It's a code for Joe Biden that comes from
a sort of confusion during a car race that
took place.
We'll explain it all, but a Southwest Airlines
pilot essentially saying if Joe Biden, during
his preflight announcement to passengers,
audible gasps were heard in the cabin and
demands for the pilot to be fired, he should
be fired.
He should be fired.
Political statements, I believe, are against
company policy for pilots, for basically every
airline.
So we will talk about that and much more when
producer Pat joins me on today's bonus show.
Get instant access by signing up
Unidentified: at joint Packman dot com.